[Music]
reaching out recording painful
[Music]
she's sideways
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what we're gonna do right here is go
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
history is gonna change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it begins on a dark I look at this
[Music]
you're not gonna find another girl like
her in a million years
[Music]
it's also magical but I've never fallen
apart that first Sunday of amended to
say
ever done I've never fallen
someday
[Music]
I ran away and I am not going back
I am NOT going back
[Music]
I ran away
and I am NOT going back let's make some
magic
Oh God
[Music]
as predicted in Cairo and Proctor fog
have your fun
there's this girl
[Music]
time in my life help you
[Music]
I ran away and I am NOT going back
I am NOT going back
[Music]
I ran away I am going I am NOT going
[Music]
Dawkins
Hawkins
[Music]
[Music]
husband
[Music]
come on
[Music]
imitating Gerald haha
oh sure
[Music]
wonderful
[Music]
[Music]
some games
[Music]
that's all goodbye thank you goodbye
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fancy seeing you again I can see through
your camera because you don't have
expressvpn thank you so much for mug
Club quarantine and the support glad to
be back and happy to announce the winner
is Tim a from Des Moines Iowa you are
the winner of our grand prize we will
fly you and a friend out to the studio
here in the great state of Texas to us
sit in our live studio audience be
featured in a sketch unless you have
some kind of a contagious virus in which
case um we will send you a fruit basket
so thank you so much for the support
everyone else enjoy the show
[Music]
listen up kids qbg talking to now while
you're outside playing with your friends
it's always smart to stay safe don't
talk to strangers also need to keep your
eye out for the strange [ __ ]
what's a [ __ ] I'll show you this is
an artist's rendition of a [ __ ] yep
that's right
[ __ ] may have done a damn good job
and the train roads but some of them are
dangerous one of them even tried to
litigate me once almost took all mr. cue
BG's gold chains but I was able to abuse
capable of that's right so if you see a
strange [ __ ] in your neighborhood
tell your parents and don't come within
six feet of them star a doesn't know now
don't be no fool stay away from the wolf
boom
okay sir you're gonna be all right we
have help on the way where are you okay
I just want to get out of here you know
okay what is anything breaking my leg
but it's not gonna work that's been no
journey go gently oh and don't worry
about it we're gonna be here we're
staying right here with you okay
so just listen to the sound of my voice
Earth when you fire perfect they don't
work they don't work don't work I kind
of sprained it pretty bad not gonna lie
but I can move it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mm that's the sound of us being back the
entire stream could just be the
demonetized logo yes so very happy but
we have the hodgetwins on the Avenue
later on today and before I go to some
announcements we've some big
announcements to make regarding some
changes here after the Mudd Club
quarantine month we appreciate you so
much for being with us but that's the
kind of the first sketch there Nana left
that you could never do on SNL no just
because people say you can't touch 911
but it's actually honoring the heroes by
showing how trivial the non-practicing
nurses are using tick tock see what you
did there how many people died because
of their choreographed dance mmm it's
tragic
I know you're busy doing the Village
People in pockets so by about half agent
Larry biller spoon is here how are you
sir great quarterblack cares
well cqb gee I don't like that audio way
doing it
shoot Maddie you can't deny me gusts me
you can fit on your back pocket but
you'll just you'll get gout she saw and
then Gerald a is here today what's the
one in there one of the day's bodyguard
bodyguard what's that in the bottle it's
it's wine what do you mean here I can
show you oh wow wow yeah turn around
there gerald yeah no no read the look no
you don't I appreciate that
crap you wrote on this bottle just now
they give you even ruins practical jokes
hundred dollar bottle before you'd crap
in a popcorn bucket and leave it in the
locker over the weekend in college you'd
like I think someone has a problem
yes you do not you do ability to defuse
the jokes even directed at him it takes
practice it was like my grandmother
operating the VCR with a giant button
what which one okay I've already
announced the winner who's going to come
out here live with us but listen we got
a lot of feedback from folks really
liked a good morning mug club if you
love something we don't want this to
stop because we like doing this with our
morning commute and we like watching it
live in the morning so new schedule
Thursday is still going to be the same
and we are going to be doing good
morning mug club going forward Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and same big ass show
live yeah so and we're still gonna do
some mash Wednesday's and we're still
gonna do some life advice so add those
so more content and we'll be with you
only streaming one every weekday morning
so on Thursday 9:00 a.m. central
attending in eastern 90% I'd like to see
you it accentuates my superiority like
me with height oh just ask er yeah well
yes I'm putting that in your permanent
record for when my people take over the
thank you we'll see maybe I think it'll
be 93 percent if we use their death rays
I don't know oh that's the crematoria
mists so also we will be in late not
late sir we'll be in the the Lansing
Capitol in Michigan by the way next
Friday that's the 22nd doing a live
peaceful respectful protest details to
follow so follow me on Instagram lad
with credit or on Twitter at s Crowder
of course we're going to be practicing
proper social distancing so use your
masks we are not there to break the law
also hint bring your full head of hair
so question of the day and there are
lannister there Lanson color are it can
put me in jail waitin for you I've even
noticed that climate change activists
and now they're trying to co-op the
corona virus they are for their own
filthy means their own wet market means
so I want to know if if you notice that
right now and I think a lot of people do
but I guess it should be to what degree
you think that a pan
it justifies a global government
takeover 50,000 trees
decided to talk about this topic but
that's a perfect segue because you're
Chinese and monkeys in your country are
apparently banded [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that acceleration that's just zero to
Mowgli and she's fine Tuesday average
white suburban mom won't see in an Asian
kid oh so cute part and parcel of living
in the alley doesn't do anything to
protect your child well not at all if
you gather it would be excusable yeah
quit again watch the reaction here here
let's play Hey look monkey comes in so
she can see it watch come on yeah she's
not lifting up a car no adrenaline turn
out to dry like this so strong and so
fast we get the motorcycle by the way
yeah where did they come from credible I
have no idea not all cultures are equal
so before we move on by the way I should
say we've gotten a new sponsor a Barbie
sparkler glasses really excited about
the product glad to have them on so keep
an eye out for the Barbie sparkler
commercial in the first commercial break
while we were we weren't off we've taped
so many sketches so many interest we
have a lot of content we had to update
all the software here but while we were
gone this was a story Canadian police
arrested someone at gunpoint assistant
at gunpoint who was dressed in a Star
Wars stormtrooper costumes complete with
a replica laser blaster because they
thought she had a real gun this comes
from left
91 reported two calls from people who
saw the girl brandishing a plastic toy
blaster they believed it was real and
we've actually obtained exclusive
footage should warn you the following
content the following altercation
footage of the police officers and the
citizen question is disturbing that's
mine
Wow 11 intro sketch without a Rodney
King pair yeah you're gonna get all the
marks really how much harder is your job
after today no I'm just thinking about
the second house thing goodbye
I can't believe nobody's sure we'd be
retreaded new ground
call us Copernicus so the female
employee was actually she was out in
full costume by the way I want to make
sure they fell it because we don't we
just but this is course and the police
didn't recognize the costume they said
that they believed her to be a member of
a militant anti-government militia yes
because militia men dress in white
plastic the strange militia head-to-toe
militia of nerds Lukas Keepers so they
like Star Trek fans I mean I don't
understand but how would you have not
seen any part of that I mean there was
there any explanation beyond it no not
much honestly for too much there may
have been but immediately my mind went
to Rodney King so that's really all I
cared about so no further research um
but we will be talking about the the UN
and Greta soon Berg so you know that'll
be more informative switching actually
the latest of course Cove at 19 News I
thought it would be done with this by
the time of the month
but it's no do you know it's no longer
about flat you thought was about
flattening the curve oh no it's about
Bill Gates making a vaccine yeah right
so take your unemployment and Windows 98
so um the latest kovat 19 is the virus
is apparently I don't like saying this
but it's been detected and semen now
this comes from Rolling Stone the study
assessed semen samples from 38 patients
found detectable levels viral loads in
the semen so this is lead the World
Health Organization of CDC and leading
health officials to chip off San
Francisco with an icepick and push it
off into the middle note
time said that it took this you don't
need to quote Gerald in California
speaking which the state they ruled that
Elon Musk and Grimes's child they cannot
legally be named this x AE a twelve
twelve so they're going up to choose a
new name so they said they'll either
name the child after the mother and call
it Claire or after the fowler father and
named it ugly bastard so that's the
choice yeah wouldn't bother that's fine
[Laughter]
like that would have saved yes it's like
everyone else's on jaws three I'm still
like it was when you thought it was safe
to go back into the water that was the
other one we're on three 3d Michael
Caine you always get the wrong viruses
I'll give you SARS three now if you want
it there always ahead of the curve there
a lot of people say that the Asians your
honor flattening number two and I'm
already on number three I appreciate
that I think a lot of people say that
the Chinese are only good at taking
technology that we develop and steal it
but the fact is they are the ones when
it comes to creating new viruses they're
like the Thomas Edison yes I've been to
cart' kindergarten I know how to share
do you they are creators Steven creators
also your communist so finally sharing
governor governor Whitmer this is
something that's been people have been
upset about I don't wanna say upset
there's been a huge reaction you know I
understand that we have to have signers
for people who are obviously yeah
hearing-impaired but there's been a
reaction to this because now it is just
the signing is distracting and it's it's
it's gotten out of hand I know that this
has been a hard time for people trying
to make ends meet when everything is
essentially shut down
and especially for small business owners
who built up something over the course
of decades and and they're worried
that's not that's not real that is
absolutely 100 really and I lady there
was a little bit of internal debate
until we paused it hands I could crack a
lobster so high they're like polar bear
paws yeah that was I mean for seeing the
hands like that was the best it's just
stuff that gives children nightmares so
here's the I understand the criticism
people would say this is a little bit
distracting but I think a lot of people
since this is sort of a local politician
who's been thrust in the national
spotlight you're not aware of this if
you know her history it's actually a
serious improvement each of the actions
that we've taken though has been because
of the incredible threat that kovat 19
is presented to our state a number of
lives lost the incredible spread in
Shiawassee County which is where this
barbershop is we have a hundred and
ninety six confirmed cases of Cove at 19
right now we've had 13 deaths in that
County alone and the protections and
that work that we've done is to protect
[Laughter]
is getting better you know I like the
fact that the slumbers are out there you
know like Dave Grohl doing signing I
mean that's amazing man you look like
Dave Grohl on there with I missed it I'm
sorry call me gerald I didn't big penis
drawn on the page in front of me and
look right past it it was that it's so
commonplace for you to see large hairy
penises that you don't even notice I
didn't see it it's like it's like for
him it's just it's like missing Waldo
Andy came for us hidden
Waldo's never there if all the states
were on a milk carton it would be
exclusively I'm like peppermint milk I
don't know why he made it so hard for
everyone to find this world out here
change the outer it every once in a
while okay so um and this is I do want
to move on so this is actually I think
going on right it might be going on at
the same time right now the the CNN
climate townhall public we don't have
the hookups right now we're again moving
some stuff around the set so we're gonna
have CNN of course up for good morning
Mudd Club but here's the thing we can't
show it right now but I can pretty much
guess how it's gonna go yeah so let me
fill you in don't know no flipping no
flipping so it's a CNN Town Hall and
this is actual it's gonna former acting
CBC director Richard Besser okay
former HHS Secretary Kathleen Sebelius
and activist Greta soon Berg what they
join Anderson Cooper and dr. Sanjay
Gupta for a live CNN Town Hall about the
corona vibe but does not look like the
other yeah when what happened to the
experts see we have the head of the CDC
mm-hmm we have a neurosurgeon yeah and
we have an autistic girl who yells how
dare you I think she's perfect for the
panel yes more important right now
according to the media than shaming
everyone for everything that they do
really good raises the intelligence I'm
not saying I agree I'm just saying you
got to respect her shameless I respect
her shame game yeah so um I do think a
couple of facts that kind of hit and
we'll discuss this a little bit of
course the left have tried to set this
up already they're attacking anyone who
questions the co vid stats they're not
even the kovat statistics but the
initial coronavirus statistics that have
been proven verifiable the 47% death
rates the two million dead by the way
the super shout out to our wonderful
researcher reg the bandit slash reg
Denise for calling Neil Ferguson that
guy we got him
so they've been trying to frame of
course everyone who says you know what I
think we need to reopen the economy I
think we need to balance lives and
livelihoods as science deniers right and
so they're trying to now equate the
denial of kovat being you know a virus
with a 10% death rate or like Ebola with
a fifty-year sent death rate we're all
it's all the same people equal deny
science just like climate change okay
we'll come back to the second aoc she
even did a video
where she was talking about kovat being
a test run for how to approach climate
change and she's been saying the green
New Deal is scientifically necessary
again let's go to the experts started
with politicians who ignored warnings by
scientists it continued through a
program of us knowing that we needed to
act quickly and needed to take dramatic
action fast in order to contain the
damage but there's so much that's
politically vested in making sure that
we don't do that right
for example this idea it's like many
scientists and epidemiologist started
saying listen we have to shut down our
cities in our state's immediately right
now just as an immediate precaution
because we did not take action earlier
the communities that suffer first are
the ones that are working class black
brown essential workers not white people
only that parallels with the climate
movement it is scientifically informed
this is scientifically informed
legislation I'm not here to tell you
what is politically easy I'm here to
tell you what is scientifically
necessary doctor I like I like her use
of the very lawyerly word inform
scientifically informed not
scientifically based not scientifically
sourced yeah and typically and I just
were you near this when he was created
around she would be served well to
attend finishing school from LeBron
James yes anyway I'm going my duty to
inform as I conversate mmm-hmm you are
just lovely here's the thing too I just
find it so funny that all of a sudden
they call their own experts yeah yeah
well why would you listen to doctor
bricks we need to listen to experts like
a ococ but the short version is that she
wants more of this yeah I love how she
just feathers in like they didn't take
the precaution did you mean we're
shutting down the world it's a
precautionary measure yeah it's a
precautionary measure like a yeah I
think I have the sniffles well as a
precautionary measure we're going to cut
off your dick oh that seemed a little
severe mmm you don't know how bad the
cold can get we're well past robitussin
MD no it's now time to lose
the D don't worry we'll draw it back on
[Laughter]
another fact the World Economic Forum
let's let's just think I I make this up
I'm trying to integrally Titus they're
now calling for a flattening of the
climate curve Oh what so many curves
it's like Raquel Welch it's so curvy
it's the work that first oh I'm
surprised they're using that now because
it's no longer about flattening the
couvade curve yeah it's about the cure
the curve is irrelevant we've already
flattened the curve who gives a rat's
ass according to ALC we shouldn't come
back until every man woman and child has
a vaccine and microchip from Bill Gates
another fact the UN chief uses Earth Day
speech to confront Trump on climate
change he was linking it of course to
coronavirus and saying that it was the
bigger threat
and then finally UC Berkeley they've
hosted a panel I think this year what's
the panel the panel is environmental and
energy experts those people like to
discuss the current kovin 19 pandemic
offer lessons and how shared global
solutions can help beat back the
continued threat of climate change so a
couple of things here by the way hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
hit all notifications because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
just check in every single day here
because we of course Crowder bits um
this is remarkable to me and I wanna
hear what you guys have to say about
this we've heard from the experts who's
denying science at this point who is
denying science when we I mean let's
just let's just use the most extreme
examples okay the most extreme examples
humanly possible the people who said
this is about comparable to the flu and
they were just scoria like I can't
believe labor they were taken behind the
woodshed
how could you downplay this versus the
initial expert who had to resign in
shame saying two million dead so let's
say it's double the number of right now
yeah right let's say we're at a hundred
and fifty thousand deaths flu season
we've had flu seasons with eighty
thousand deaths versus two million it is
so much closer to the crazy non experts
who said it's more comparable to the flu
that it wouldn't even appear on the same
line chart absolutely and one of the
first things that they said was that
John Cornyn tweeted out he said after
this is all done we need to have a
good-faith discussion about these models
and that's what they said made him Aidan
right because he's like oh these models
we need to have a good fake discussion
about what's going on here because it
said two million and now it says nothing
close to that right and that's what they
really I can't I can't even have a
conversation thing is about that model
we have a whole we have a new model
that's how it works like Victoria's
Secret shelf life on that it's pretty
short yeah let me guess this model has
more curves yes it used to be about
curves not flattening them right but
having them yeah no exactly no this is
now we have a new model and so I wonder
when they say we're going to get rid of
misinformation on social media you know
Twitter Facebook YouTube well on a
second I mean does that include the
World Health Organization saying that it
couldn't be transmitted from human human
contact oh well no no we won't remove
that because that's what we believed at
the time of the information we had
Taiwan saying have a minute so so many
media requests Brendan yeah and why did
you believe it because of the tweets the
tweet what about the tweets out there
from the Chinese ambassador who said
that it was started by American troops
well that was based on the information
we had at that time come against it oh
you're gonna have a problem with pizza
gate but not the Chinese ambassador
saying it was marine you saw Avatar
[Laughter]
doesn't seem that movie is remarkable to
me how inconsistent it is here here's
what we said early on I think okay
understand a precautionary measure when
we didn't have any data exactly we
didn't have any information okay you
shut down for a little bit or you take
some precautionary measures we
quarantine the sick and the vulnerable
because I've typically what you do you
quarantine a sick not the Haiti yeah
that's understandable especially what we
were hearing from China by the way in
their World Health Organization that it
could be a seven pretty well of course
we want to do that but now in the face
of overwhelming data where even leftist
governors tell us okay it's about a
point five percent death rate now at the
top end in the face of data you are
still pushing to ruin people's lives why
well you know what why listen to allow
us to make our case as we present the
experts Greta
your witness
well and and it that they're using the
same term that evidently worked to make
people shut down the entire economy
it makes you realize oh that's the goal
yes okay well let's use the same terms
that at least are gonna have the same
results right and that's what they're
going for yeah and in the article that
even went back just going back on that
point said that if the the basic thing
was saying that people were a climate
denier there's same people that are
saying the covin thing wasn't that the
models weren't wrong it's just that we
had stuff happen like you social
distancing happen right close it down
we're like wait a minute no you factored
that in to begin with right and you said
that even with that this was going to be
the case right so tell me in the climate
thing what you're going to do yeah then
you're gonna change the model and then
you're gonna move the goalposts again
and then you're gonna exclude China from
the equation and then we're still
organized a been wrong it ever nearly
every single things I don't want to be
Donald Trump that like they've been
wrung at every single turn everyone
nasty they were wrong about Georgia yeah
they're wrong about Georgia and so they
have to move the goalposts now - no - no
longer the goal posts are no longer well
hostage everyone's gonna die if you open
up your economy because in Texas guess
what nowhere near as severe as Michigan
nowhere near the kind of infection we
have a lot of big cities here in Texas
it's not just some small state with
podunk towns we were reasonable in our
approach and I'm not saying that not
happening lockdowns is more effective
than having lock downs I'm saying there
is no rhyme or reason to the at this
point when you look at the statistics
outside of the fact that it's dangerous
if you're over 80 or have pre-existing
comorbidities that's what we know the
rest we don't they said everyone's gonna
die needlessly in Georgia well Georgia
is now beyond the curve right well
they're doing just fine like they're
saying kind of this cliff fall-off that
we talked about but we're just fine
because of course every life matters
worse and but compared to the risk that
we are used to taking every single day
of our lives that maybe we just didn't
know that we were taking every year we
have a flu risk every year we have a
death by automobile accident risk or by
murder or by something happening in the
hospital when you go in for a procedure
that's not supposed to kill you that
accidentally does and all my sires
showing up in the sequel well that's
true a really good point I mean the
I know well but the comparison to
reality of how many lives are actually
lost and the changes it's not just about
how many more lives have been lost due
to kovat but can compare to what our
normal death rates would have been
compared to the risk like you're saying
yeah and when you actually do then
you're not just screaming about politics
and and people saying if you open the
economy you hate every human being right
it just it all falls apart
well you had a point you were making
before the show too that you see this as
a push for a global government I do I
think that you know there was no
question that earlier pre Korona there
was a push for having that type of
globalization interconnectedness and
ultimately a level of authority beyond
just the UN and Geneva Conventions and
those types of things but but to say you
know that the United States and other
countries should cede their authority to
international governments to control
these issues and that's not to say that
it's not better for us to cooperate but
there's a difference between cooperation
and ceding authority and here now the
push has become even further
well we couldn't use Korona to push it
because obviously Coronis says you need
to go the opposite direction you make
sure you're independently based you're
not as dependent on foreign powers and
global supply chains but so now they're
having to say well okay that's not
working so let's move to the other one
and it's not to say again the
cooperation isn't important or that
there isn't some concern in at a global
level for the environment right but that
doesn't mean that we take the
GranTurismo Greta Thornburg version of
going out there and just everyone has to
listen to ya the UN on everything or
listen to her not only she's not a
scientist I'm pretty sure she's never
made the baking soda lemon juice volcano
how could she know where's the lemon
juice is it vinegar and baking soda
I think next week that'll be a
commercial what we about to say there
well it's so one of the other points
that they brought up is that the kovat
19 virus is nature's warning so this is
this is Mother Nature literally it was
in the article it said this is mother
nature's warning that we have to listen
to he's back on the ferngully but I mean
think about think about how dumb that
sounds like climate change is so bad
that Mother Nature is saying well if
they don't listen on this maybe they'll
listen to this virus now get the bigger
picture like that's what they're saying
they're gonna have
that that's a crazy leap I couldn't even
make that leap yeah doesn't work yeah
absolutely you know I will say there a
couple lessons that we've learned from
code we have the hodgetwins coming up
after this we're gonna be talking about
what was I just forgot oh ma i mode how
do you pronounce it just a mod because
it has a you and I vote I knew a guy a
mod who didn't have a you oh I don't
want to get it wrong because that's that
that's the most dangerous landmine in
covering that topic 9/11 sketch Rodney
quality and the hodgetwins to discuss
hot Aubrey it's gonna be good chef what
could go wrong just like we've learned
this one we're talking about the economy
we've had some lessons that we've
learned from us right here the federal
government can't be a charity this is
well you know the federal government can
help right now a couple of things that
shows you how politicize it is because
right now Democrats and all the
Republicans are holding up this new
stimulus bill hold a second who held up
the stimulus bill before we flattened
the curve remember you guys wanted to
shove it everything in there with
earmark unity Center funding it was a
business that we need to do this so that
we can flatten the curve
now that we've flattened the curve and
you're talking about another stimulus
which a lot of it can be a big giant
kickback to the postal union when you
actually look at what they want to do at
this point we'll pass the curve now
you're trying to play politics with it
and say Republicans are trying to stop
the spending bill you guys were doing it
when we actually needed it but let's
assume for a second when people say well
there's there's no choice between making
a living right in the economy or staying
healthy if the government just does its
job how much money have we spent now
true numbers truly many trillions about
more than at more more than ever as far
as acute spending in the history of the
United States that floated us for a
month yeah if that so how much if you
spend more right you spy let's you know
let's call it 20 trillion dollars our
entire debt clock three 53.59 enough
money and by the way it runs out faster
if nobody is worried so we've learned
that the federal government cannot be a
charity it's not Samaritan's Purse but
you know what else that businesses at
this it's a self-sustaining charity you
go to your local coffee shop you go to
your restaurant that allows them to
provide a living not only for the
business owners but their employees when
you are voluntarily offering money for
goods or services and something else I
think is
undeniable here while we're talking
about the climate change dream movement
they want to equate the two and you know
what so do I just like they wanted you
to remember coronavirus and Donald
Trump's handling of it going into
November yeah I want you to remember all
of it two million dead 7% deaths right
please do not forget we've been
consistent I want you to remember when
they accuse us of being science deniers
because of our position on coronavirus
here's something interesting to me this
has proven beyond any shadow of a doubt
that absolutely positively roaming Trump
no exceptions no exceptions how many I
should none me hear me stutter do I do I
look like a cast that the green movement
hates people think about this for I was
at I was at a co-op health food store in
Michigan by the way huge culture of fear
in Michigan compared to Texas yeah
I was walking in to get some get some
yogurt I have a mask because you have to
otherwise it's illegal this lady who's
my age has a mask and I'm walking
pastoring at yogurt and she looks she
stops panics and leaps in the next
island oh my god
and then when I go to check out they
have a big sign like it is with it is
with extreme extreme sadness that we
have to inform you do to the coronavirus
we are not accepting reusable bags at
this time that we are not accepting
reusable cups at this time I'm a second
a flush Lucerne 'el how'd you figure
that out by the way there's no secret to
it you're pissed just stays there yeah
it just pulls it can you put even the
sports bars put in ice or peanut shells
or some fleshless you're like well
that's kind of gross and then like well
I'm gonna go wash my hands and sing
happy birthday twice and happy birthday
to happy and the sink shuts off cause
it's a green sink and I can't use paper
towels cuz it's a blow dryer every when
it comes down to saving human lives all
of us we have to get rid of the
absurdity of the plastic that the
reusable bags by the way are worse for
the environment and the reusable cup
from not gonna do that anymore what
about following the CDC hand-washing
guidelines I can't do it it's not
humanly possible what about the flush
list urinals
Hey no more flush
no more running water that's progress
I'm going to piss my name into a tree is
that progress that's skill this is what
the left would see when they see the SOE
man going up going up and then down to a
squatty potty and then eventually it's
made of hemp and there's ed we're in San
Francisco so when we're talking about
this yes listen my position and I think
everyone here on Climate change's no no
listen I think the earth has warmed I
think that humans may be contributing a
significant amount to it as to whether
it will have catastrophic results I'm
not entirely sure as to the proposed
global legislation that would kill
people undeniably expecting of course
China to play ball which they've read
vocally expressed they will not no I
don't believe that politically it will
make any difference and as it relates to
coronavirus I believe it relied to or at
the very least provided misinformation
certainly from China certainly from
experts if we can have two million
people dead I've literally shut down the
economy based on statistics that
couldn't exactly be observed you know
what is observable you know it's 100
cent observable joblessness oh people
not making any money
Yeah right suicides going left all isn't
going up there's no doubt about that so
when you folks want to say hey we deny
the experts by the way Burke's not an
expert oh my so Chih oh I will wear it
proudly sure I'm skeptical of the Kyoto
Accord sorry now Parrish probe Kyoto
Accord Paris Protocol Paris agreement
Jessica love that no it's not a court
you're wrong you're Asian you should
know it I know that's not Chinese but
civic honda oh okay go ahead I was
looking I was on a roll none of this was
good I liked your role but I'm gonna
interrupt it when you talk about whether
or not you're gonna have climate deniers
and you have folks who say they're for
the climate in this environmental change
you know what the basics are when you
take what they want to a logical
extension you cannot have jobs jobs are
a thing the advance of Technology mining
for precious materials to be able to use
in the technology that is actually being
used to make ventilators or life-saving
technology all that requires solar
panels
yeah solar they're not made from
sunshine and fleshless urinals exactly
all of those things require a use of the
environment there's no question that we
need to do it in a safe way but right
and and certainly in a safe way to
protect human lives
but without any question we have to be
able to continue this march of progress
in a direction that allows for using the
environment whereas the the green
movement is unquestionably against jobs
against economies against communities
yeah and against not just our nation but
any nation and what's so funny to me as
they talk about you know this global
economy right there we are all one we
are the world hold hands and have all
the flags effectively an Amish quilt but
really when you think about it okay you
look at the globe and you look at the
green movement and then they have the
gall to tell us well really the people
most affected by environmental
pollutants are minorities in the United
States and people most affected by
coronavirus in United States are black
people okay hold on a second who's most
affected by the green New Deal who's
most affected by the coda Protocol which
would skyrocket energy costs which for
us is mildly inconvenient because you
drive across over but for someone in
Zambia or honestly you want to go that
far for someone in Mexico if you can
wander out of your cancun booze cruise
resorts they work all week just to get
enough fuel so they can heat a can of
beans on an old ironing board in a drum
who do you think is most affected by
your green policy it's inconvenient for
us it kills people in the third world
who make $2 a month so they don't really
care about the most vulnerable among us
certainly I don't want to say no one
cares I'm saying the policies are not
thoughtful of the most vulnerable among
us because it is all a sacrifice at the
altar of the greater good what's the
greater good well the climate the earth
it's more important than people what's
the greater good with coronavirus well
political expediency it's more important
than people being autonomous and being
able to make their own livings so I
won't I'm not gonna make any sacrifices
that adulterer and as it relates to
being anti science being I'm a climate
denier as well as a coronavirus denier I
think you can look at the track record
of where we lined up on climate change
where we've lined up on coronavirus and
it's remarkable remarkable that we've
gotten very little wrong honestly I was
speaking I got thinking this is gonna
come back to bite many ass instead I
look like Nostradamus so I will wear
that loudly and proudly yep call me a
science denier but I'll be sure to check
in with Greta after this right now
hodgetwins coming up
[Music]
this is Franklin he looks so happy
doesn't he
that's because he's about to be turned
into a pair of Barbie sparker glasses
it's quite a process but we're here to
guide you through it first Franklin will
be removed from his shelf then his shell
will be crushed into hundreds of tiny
pieces these pieces will then be melted
together into a sheet and cut by a large
machine into your designer frame of
choice after a final quality check
Franklin is ready to be sent out to you
the customer wondering what happens to
the rest of Franklin well here at Barbie
sparker we believe in giving back that's
why for every pair of Barbie sparker
glasses ordered we send one can of
turtle soup to a Chinese homeless
shelter of your choice thanks Barbie
sparker and Thank You Franklin
[Music]
I think everybody's gone yeah it looks
like everyone's gone in the back to
Allah I'll get the snacks and stuff you
want to fire up the projector you go
brought you beverage oh thank you have
you seen this one yet
oh yeah see like eight times but find
something new each viewing at least what
you do online is your business protect
your business with expressvpn well that
seems like a fun date slash movie night
if you're not using expressvpn it's like
leaving your front door open by the way
for not using any VPN and I recommend
expressvpn because they're one of the
only bpn I know of as far the major VPNs
that didn't have any kind of a security
reach without telling people so it's the
VPN that we use here to secure Internet
data just click one button on your
computer or your smartphone you are
protected so visit please my special
link right now to expressvpn dot-com
slash Crowder you can extra three months
of expressvpn free what you do online
should be your own business even as
offensive disgusting or depraved it may
be I don't know just protect your
internet today with the VPN that I trust
we all use here that's expressvpn
accomplish what's going on here y'all
breaking mr. Kubi geez number-one rule
what's that social distancing gee we're
sorry qbg we forgot to stand six feet
apart and I guess six feet apart what
you talk about you're standing too close
to that shadow man it's called Chinese
virus for a reason I don't know if well
mister qbg knows you need to keep your
distance and the wolf flu can't hurt you
now many ways to spread the virus we
need every man woman and child working
together to stop matter of credit
Comstock smoked club I suggested to you
your friends and your family
[Music]
all right very glad to have our next
guests a little spoiler alert it has
been a little while they were supposed
to be the finale on our CNN for our live
stream but I went into my tirade against
shut up well mo because you know but
here's the thing
I only only target the strong because
with Chris Cuomo it doesn't happen by
accident that's true
so as being what she's next to you guys
would probably make Chris Cuomo look
like a small child cry like one too he's
Prince you can follow them on the
Twitter at hodgetwins in there they have
a YouTube channel out few hundred
thousand subscribers doing really well
doing good conservative twins and it's
the hodgetwins on Facebook so many twins
the hodgetwins Kevin and Keith how are
you sirs I don't know why do you have to
go to the race thing right away we are
the world hey this is the first time
I've seen you what's a beard is this
because of the quarantine or I thought
you guys couldn't grow facial hair is
your slave name and join the Nation of
Islam yeah I noticed this when I was in
the drugstore speaking of the racial
thing there's an entire line of products
for black men facial hair like for razor
bump bump away and stuff that's that's a
whole new world to me yeah man yeah
please do not laugh at my pain it's a
deal
it's called spider if you're good at
selling a sponsor don't do it free don't
mention the name and then we'll approach
bump fighter and set it up it's like a
lacquer for black people beards you
should be getting paid for this ya bum
fighter I mean that's one hell of a
sponsor yes
that's ta on YouTube you're in the
premium category its bum fighter
it's just Carlton from Fresh Prince
who's doing this in the mirror and
you're like oh though I should have
known you'd steal the job from under a
cellphone so I was so disappointed when
I found out that Carlton was actually
Carlton in real life you just hoped he
was like a you know a black Daniel
day-lewis and you realize no you no one
noticed him he's a one-note actor but
he'll be 'no it'll make a killing in
hallmark films okay so before i want to
talk about a mod aubrey because you guys
really some videos on this and i want to
be clear for people who are out there
watch the whole videos in context right
so I'm going I know that this is a show
so I have to run a clip but I encourage
you to watch the full videos in context
because if you look at people who've
covered the videos they've taken them
out of context people get really mad but
if you look at the comments in the full
videos people go oh this is pretty
balanced and an objective so that being
said here is a clip which may be
offensive but funny Hey look be honest
ain't nuttin racist so it's gonna be
race look just be honest everybody I
mean stuff races this is just what I
observed in my lifetime okay be honest
everybody black or white or Asian
Hispanic whatever think about this when
was the last time you seen a black man
jogging in your neighborhood
I mean playing basketball and football
does not count
you take that ball away you just chill
that black man's motivation for jock
look I've lived in white neighborhoods I
lived in black neighborhoods the only
time I've seen a black man chocolate is
when he's renting from somebody it was
for life preservation it wasn't a get
his heart rate up hey we don't swim
either I mean I go to the gym I see
black people lifting weights and playing
basketball I've never seen a black man
in the pool I mean jogging and swimming
is not our thing that's racist but it's
a good point
I thought your gig at the Apollo was
canceled too Co vid I stand corrected so
let me clear here you guys got death
threats for that yeah just to clarify I
mean a motto buries in his early 20s
black kids at that age they go for
exercise they don't go jogging they lift
weights they play ball yeah I mean just
like black folks is everything most so
mean country music yes just an
observation there we are
because it wasn't the country music half
the singer sound like you because I say
he was laying dead Street with a TV I
was joking
towards the two white guys it's perfect
I didn't have all the facts brown slate
whiter stop stop did you hey did you see
him running down his feet with a TV on
his back that was a joke toaster wiped
him and that the black guy no and I want
to be really clear that was very funny
and that wasn't about Ahmad Aubrey if
you watch it you guys said these are the
facts that we know and you lay it out
and you even did an update when the
video came out and I have to be a full
disclosure here you know last week we
were working on taping sketches and we
were working behind the scenes because
we'd the Mudd Club quarantine months so
I shut off from news that I can focus on
some of the work that needs to come in
and it was hard for me to keep track or
to get info when I was searching on this
so I want to be clear people no no there
there's a joke right separate from and
then you guys I think we're pretty fair
and covering the Ahmad Aubree case of
let people know who don't exactly know
because it's hard for me and it's how I
make a living to kind of navigate my way
through it
what exactly happened here where are we
well don't be bashful now he's already
out of the bottle stops around does
videos it's like he's tasting it to us
he runs in hats right stays left three
minutes the neighbors seen him spooked
them he takes off running because yeah I
mean you got somebody yelling yeah that
would take the attempt to arrest him he
actually charges the cow shotgun at that
point you can either charge him with
aggravated assault
you can even charge those strong on
Rodriguez just trying to take possession
of your shotgun yeah in the video it's a
life and death struggle yeah because of
this accident because of the three
felonies he just committed they have
every right to shoot and kill him yeah
that's all I don't know who actually
shot him what well they said it was a
close range the shotgun it was the
shotgun yeah but we really don't know if
the girl went off by mistake mistakes or
anything yeah it was just one shot right
well the thing to me is this is a very
unfortunate situation right well all
around I want to say but we don't have
all of the information I will say this
obviously it would be better if the guy
had not been shot and obviously he's
reeling comes up with a shotgun I
understand a chiral to react and defend
yourself
but something that changes that which we
don't know yet did the guy who called
the police so they obviously don't it
doesn't seem like you were planning on
shooting an unarmed black man if they
call the police and say hey we're here
please go take care of this please
follow this seems to me like maybe they
approached him and said what are you
doing asked him some questions and then
he panicked and attacked them two
different scenarios okay a guy who's
maybe standing
social distancing standing six seven
feet of the shotgun aim into the ground
like hey man we've had some break-ins
here what are you doing you mind
answering some questions right at that
point it'd be oh okay oh I'm sorry so
yeah I was just jogging or if the guy a
person with a shotgun at point-blank
like what do you do and
you know then the guy has the right to
defend himself but we don't know that
yet and based on what are you here to
the 9-1-1 call it doesn't it could they
be vigilantes guys who are tough guys
maybe but we don't know and that's
what's so concerning to me is we don't
know and right away you go well done
we're gonna have to fill in the blanks
like Trayvon Martin and brown are we
gonna wait yeah I mean I'm going commit
a hate crime I'm not calling the cops
yeah that's a good point
you distilled everything that I said I
was long-winded and yours was far better
I mean the media was just talking to a
neighborhood trying to get some exercise
the only time I saw a Maury jog in mud
Amala jogging was into the house in the
house from the scene of a crime yeah I
don't know this is true enough but they
say it was 12 miles from his house
this guy's got been damn good shape that
feeds on 12 house this house and he's
pretty talk that's a damn marathon yeah
lanes why he's walking in the video
maybe he's tired right yes yes make
sense
all the evidence I've see in this video
him stopping to look around the sprint
in the house
you know being spooked in people and he
takes off running and detained it did
steal his fate in my book and I don't
see how anybody can defend his when he
runs around the truck he could have kept
straight Brennan but he decided to run
into the big Michael son and grab a
shotgun if he actually charged him with
me young man lost his life book come on
yeah I've also in your video you said
that you would tell your son's that if
ever they were approached with a gun and
someone said you know a we call the
police to wait for the police to try and
deescalate the situation play devil's
advocate a little bit here we'll say
listen there's information that we have
that he didn't we know that these guys
called the cops of father and son I keep
forgetting it's like some McMichaels
McMichaels yeah we know that they call
the police officers that being said a
mod didn't so there is there could be a
scenario for example let's say it's it
could be your son or it could be anybody
where someone says
hey we've called the cops stay where you
are and you could think what if they're
trying to kidnap me I don't know what
they've called the cops and that could
be a flight or flight response so that's
why I say we don't know as to whether
the reaction was it could have been
appropriate we know that they did call
the cops but you know that at the time
so is that at all something you sort of
comes into play here that why would he
trust they've called the cops yeah yeah
who knows
yeah it's that's the only thing I
understand D I will okay look white
privilege check here my friend Joey what
we used to do this after working
construction we would walk on the golf
course in st. Lambert in Quebec and we
would spot the houses that were empty
and had pools and what we would do is we
would hop the fence and cool off at the
end of the day in a pool now victimless
trespassing absolutely but we
predetermined that if someone came out
we would immediately be apologetic and
I'm so sorry so now again if some guy
comes out with a shotgun what are you
doing here I'm not gonna follow him to
get my towel and walk out and assault
them obviously I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
I totally have no business being in your
pool would add hot then poor but if they
come into the water right up with me
with you know with a spear gun then I
might fight for my life so you know that
being said looking back probably not the
best decision that's it I had nothing I
had no question for you so how what do
you think we'll be seeing as this are
you not hearing magazine what oh my god
for crying out loud are you still there
hodgetwins you can well yeah that sucked
so what happened yeah what is ute and
forget to onion no you were talking to
you
[Laughter]
wait how was I can you show me again
uncanny so I just say that upon
retrospect it was a bad decision for me
to make what do you think we'll see is
this sort of unfurls here this case I
mean everybody so biased people like
whoever sustainable from our general
stand on him even if these guys these
guys are found not guilty I mean I just
think the situation could have been
handled totally different yeah I mean I
have a good firm this type of CCW I use
it to preserve life I'm not you trying
to play Rambo and arrest people right
the most I would you did in that
situation if I'm gonna had to do
something was to call the cops and maybe
follow them to the cops show up the
ground
that's the only thing how would he did
yeah that's how the six-way should've
been I let this guy know Mikey's retired
cop is no ordinary citizen so he's
arrested plenty of people I mean is it's
kind of hard for me to tell this man not
not I mean what to do in his own
neighborhood he said he's out under
walls you can make a system Reza
personally I wouldn't have done it
yeah cause whenever you confronted
criminal law somebody just committed a
crime or whatever you don't know how are
you gonna react yes one thing for a cop
to stop somebody in a reaction here dude
you don't have no uniform you don't have
no badge yeah you may disturb you got
any that's why you're actively did
that's why I wouldn't wait for the cops
somebody in uniform to make them yeah
but somebody reasonable if I don't win
somebody's house I know I'm breaking
along if I take all the win and somebody
gives chase I'm gonna stop that's what a
reasonable person would have done if
they're scared but I don't know what
this man was thinking when he did only
attack the man yeah I guess you just
wanted to wait to the trial yeah I think
we have to wait I think there is a there
are a couple of lessons that can be
learned right now if we go watching
we're gonna go to a web extended and
talk fitness and Quarantine in a little
bit I think the two lessons that I see
from this before we have all the
information it's trying to remove ego
from the equation because we can see
that with we look at Trayvon there's an
ego thing there if he didn't get on top
of Zimmerman and punch him Zimmerman's a
dick we know that now but he'd be alive
if Mike Brown had gotten out of the
street like Darren Wilson requested
instead of punching a cop to prove he'd
be alive right now
in this case but we don't know if was
ego driven but I think for
one out there don't let ego make your
decisions when you're in a pressure
cooker when you don't when you're in a
volatile situation and the other thing I
think
don't bring a firearm out of your out of
your holster don't ever bring it into
the equation unless you understand that
that immediately escalates it and
there's a strong likelihood or a
stronger likelihood that you might have
to use it I think everyone needs to
follow that like if you're calling the
cops call the at that point call the
cops
wait for the cops to come keep trailing
the people at the cops do their job
don't call the cops and then also show a
gun cuz you never know how someone's
gonna react and I think that's
understandable right I got one please
Steven you know three of these
situations I got a good idea just don't
hit anybody or attack anybody all three
these men will be still alive that's a
good point - yeah generally as a rule of
thumb don't violently assault anyone
period so good I'll be sure to get your
words of wisdom - Chris Cuomo we'll see
if he lets it absorb but maybe by
osmosis okay it is the conservative
twins on YouTube the hodgetwins on
Facebook for people who are watching
this on YouTube we're gonna go to web
extended exclusive to my clubs
[Music]
okay so I've showed you how to make pour
over arrow press but some of you are
saying yeah man I like my Keurig machine
I don't like you and I don't want your
money
but if you are married to a Keurig
machine I do have some hacks that will
get the best out of it that you can
first thing is of course you need good
coffee to start with and there you have
it black rifle coffee coms flash Crowder
enter the promo code Crider you get 20%
off these cups typically have 11 grams
of coffee which will make all the
difference in the world I'm gonna weigh
this for you so we can see you can see
11.2 I actually left some in there it's
closer to 12 grams with these black
rifle cups first thing I'm gonna do is
run some hot water through this machine
into my cup now why does that help a lot
of these machines don't get hot enough
so running some hot water through it
first we'll prime the mechanism all
right now that's ready I'm going to put
the round in close it up tight now
here's the tip the biggest problem with
these Keurig machines is that the water
runs through too quickly with the coffee
it often runs through sometimes 45
seconds or a minute and people think oh
my coffee my coffee is so fast in the
morning sure but you're drinking [ __ ]
you are drinking the good news is I have
a trick that will help improve it what I
do is I hit brew for just enough time
for it to saturate the coffee grounds
and once it starts to drip even a little
bit I'm gonna stop it you're gonna see a
little bit of a trickle I let that
saturate for a little bit of time now
that it's been sitting for a little bit
of time I'm going to make one six ounce
cup and now I'm gonna hit room we've
just eliminated the variables that
typically make a really crappy cup of
coffee for most of these namely more
coffee it's fresh roasted from black
rifle you have eleven to twelve grams as
opposed to 8 and most cups the
temperature is hot enough and we've
increased the contact time between the
water and the coffee for something that
is that's alright I am NOT waiting what
are your first but so I would kill all
your children for a lot of these cigars
can Stephen really be trusted just say
no to steven crowder and mug club paid
for by moms can smoke club calm
[Music]
louder with prouder ranger pants
buy yours today at louder with prouder
shop calm
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
that's called the really married to that
Sears catalog JCPenney Christmas photo
Oh was not even under what yeah it's
dedication with that different shades of
gray background in Italian send it out I
need to do a school pictures um to do
that school photos horrible experience
horrible
they ever tell you they do that at our
high school for a graduation photos and
they brought like a makeup artist no for
kids
well high school senior years by the way
extended interview of course hodgetwins
will be available for those four mug
Club members we start good morning well
club next week and we will be in the
Michigan next Friday with a peaceful
legal protest to reopen the economy um
yeah they brought in makeup for my
senior year picture and the worst part
about it for you know almost the
opposite of the direction of this story
which is why it was just shattering to
my self-confidence because you have to
stand in line and watch them you know
doll up everybody out right sure and you
see like oh that's uh someone three
three people up she's getting about ten
minutes okay that's a mr. Springer he's
getting about okay two minutes and then
I went and I said you know horrible like
pizza flick acne and is she and she
clearly just like looked at me went and
just grabbed at what he called powder
puffs those things they platter but I
noticed it was everyone else had like
spray and brush labels me it was just
like 200 really I don't think this day
that it's available anywhere else now
watch them was gonna call it it's
disgusting
I was very gross I wonder they don't
have pock marks worse than then the best
friend in Truman Show mmm only Owen
Mills knows his name
I have no idea thank you guys it was fun
glad being back you know you know I
wanted to talk with you guys about
something a little bit I let me sort of
preface this because I did ask him and
he said it was okay to to talk about our
meeting I did actually make the trip to
Leland our County Michigan we talked
about the sheriff
a long time ago not a long time I he was
he feels like a long time ago a few
weeks ago I believe his name is a
pronoun
Bork of it sure Sheriff cherish cherish
sport he was horrible his parents named
him Sharon they just wanted they wanted
every single conversation to start with
cherish Borka [ __ ] there in Lenoir
County I made the trip out there because
I know he had caught a lot of flack he
was the one in the media who said that
he wasn't going to enforce the
unconstitutional portions of governor
Whitmer's orders now I want to be clear
we were sitting more than six feet apart
he had a we both had masks on practicing
social distancing of course he supports
that and he's talked about that with his
statements what he showed me were all of
these letters from people before he
issued a statement like hey I'm a purge
fisherman and am I gonna get arrested
because they have a motor on my boat or
hey you know what I'm going to this park
and I want to make sure that I'm not
arrested because I have an anniversary
with my wife because people are getting
fined and arrested and what he was
saying was listen I'm not going to do
that I don't have the authority to do
that as a sheriff but I will break it up
I will break it up and I will tell you
to be sensible but I'm not gonna put you
in cuffs I'm not going to give you a
fine and that was blown out of
proportion of course misinterpreted so I
had a long conversation with this guy
really accomplished guy to really just
just a sweet guy in people there you
know loved him in that County um and we
were talking about anxiety so he
mentioned this because you know he works
with a lot of veterans and he said I see
a lot of these young people especially
now in Michigan who are smoking dope and
they need it because of their the excuse
they always used as anxiety that's
because you know the legalization in
Michigan now and there's all this zoning
and they're calling it the cannabis
lottery and he said you know I have a I
don't know if he mentioned his brother
as friends you know one my grandfather
came back from World War two missing a
leg you know and he didn't have you
don't think he had anxiety so you know I
had a friend from Vietnam who who came
back and was missing an eye and so don't
talk to me about anxiety referring to
Millennials and I said you know what
hold on a second let me pause it
something for a minute and and we
ultimately came to more of an
understanding I think people need to
understand that yeah I think a lot of
Millennials out there I think a lot of
young people do suffer from anxiety and
I do think that they can have anxiety
that is worse than people from the
greatest generation you know people who
are out there in World War two
and let me explain to you why and this
is why I think we're seeing a lot of it
with coronavirus right you really
shouldn't be that anxious if you believe
that it's a period of two months or even
if it's a period of a year and things
will go back to normal and basically
stay home and collect a check that
shouldn't be super anxiety inducing
certainly not as anxiety inducing as
storming the beaches of Normandy but you
know what I see and I get a lot of
letters from you guys and girls out
there and gals guys and gals you got the
horse right here don't let me get into
Ethel Merman anxiety is often a symptom
of purposelessness that's what makes
people anxious and I tell you that's why
a lot of business owners themselves are
very anxious because they don't have
someone telling you what to do you have
to make up what it is to do I know audio
ed you said during the Mudd Club
quarantine month you would often be so
tired sometimes at the end of the day
because you would have to have all these
conversations and direct people and
didn't always have as much to show for
it physically like well I didn't write
these jokes or I didn't but I had to
make sure that these trains ran on time
sure and that can create a lot of
anxiety for people because is wrongfully
so in that case I mean sometimes people
feel like well I haven't I haven't
accomplished anything but you see that
with a lot of young people with this
they're going out into the world and
yeah sure I think it's valid I think
rather than just dismissing Millennials
a lot of people do this I think it's
wrong to say okay boomer and the only
reason people say okay boomer is because
really you have a generation that was
flowerpower hippies ticking daisies and
rifles and now they elected Ronald
Reagan and Donald Trump so they're mad
at boomers they're mad at the hippies
because they want to be San Francisco
retreads today so let's be really clear
I hate the okay boomers thing but also
they don't people just dismiss
Millennials as oh they're entitled what
do they have to be anxious about well
they have a few things to be anxious
about on a very observable level right
they're going out into a far more
crowded more competitive work space but
to get more specific I hear this a lot
where they say you know when I grew up
we didn't have these phones we didn't
have smart phones we didn't have all
this access to technology we had to go
off to war do I think that a millennial
who's leaving College with the Gender
Studies degree or with a liberal arts
degree with a creative arts degree or
German poetry or underwater
basket-weaving take your pick do I think
that them leaving college today
living at home not gainfully employed is
it possible that they are more anxious
than the 16 year old who was drafted
fighting in world war ii absolutely
absolutely no that's not to say that
their their tasks or their life is any
more important no in fact the exact
opposite and that's what I think people
are missing we think we're trying to
solve this problem of an anxiety is a
symptom of purposelessness people are
anxious right now because they're
floundering they're not going to work
they don't have anything to do you often
think man if I didn't have to work I'd
be able to stay home and sit in the
couch and watch TV that's fun for a
couple of days and then that anxiety
that worthlessness comes into effect
because human beings were made to work
human beings were made to fulfill a
purpose let me ask you this do you think
that when someone for example was in a
foxhole world war two out there
take your pick somewhere across Europe
right with the fight in the axis there
and our campaign do you think that we're
sitting there going like nah man I just
don't know if what I'm doing is what I'm
doing is making an impact no you knew
what you had to do is it scary
sure is it terrifying absolutely my
grandfather in law was a Abama deer in
World War two i watch people cry at his
funeral who were soldiers folding up the
flag they're not supposed it was that
powerful but those people knew what they
were doing they knew what they were
trying to accomplish
they know there were a lot of Americans
who were referred to as Playboy's right
non-interventionist then Pearl Harbor
happened all right now you got to deal
with some Japan and Germany so they knew
this is a righteous fight I may I may
lose my life but I'm doing it for a
valid reason and I think a lot of people
misinterpret this where they go oh my
gosh the higher the danger the higher
the risk the more anxiety no not
necessarily because a portion of that
equation is purpose and if you know that
hey there's a chance you might lose your
life here but it's because you're trying
to stop the greatest evil that's ever
happened in humanity from marching
across the rest of Europe and then
finally make it across the pond well
guess what you're willing to pay that
price and it's not anxiety because you
don't know what's coming next
it's anxiety because you know what
you've accepted what's coming next and
it's anxiety because
want to make sure that the people you
love back home are provided for that's
very different from I'm anxious because
I don't know what to do and that's a
problem that we need to solve and that's
why I see people like like Jocko and
sometimes this show and we do the life
advice seems to help people because
coddling folks making sure they don't
have a big red marker on any test that
doesn't make people more confident what
it does is it ill prepares them for the
real world
think about this we had a generation
let's look at the greatest generation
that's that's what we call them World
War two we had people who went to school
right they were doing basic math they
were doing basic English they were
reading the classics that many of them
weren't doing advanced trigonometry many
of them didn't go to college and then
they would go to war a lot of them and
then they were working the same job
until they retired at the age of 65
right and most things were made in
America they knew that there was an
opportunity for them now in this
scenario we have kids who are going to
school becoming totally ill-equipped for
the real world back then they allowed
court they allowed corporal punishment a
kid could go to school get beaten with a
switch from his teacher and have the
teacher had the full authority to bring
up the paddle at any port that they
wanted a teacher could yank on their ear
they had a really tough go there were no
anti-bullying campaigns and that toughen
them up for the world now we have kids
going to school who live in safe spaces
who aren't challenged who aren't at all
dealing with any kind of adversity not
everyone but a lot of people and then
they go out into a world that doesn't
have the security did our fathers and
our grandfathers had no one no one in
our did you ever leave school thinking
that you were gonna have a job with
benefits pension retirement package
until 865 no you jump around that's most
people our age because you have to and
so we have people less equipped going
into a world that's going to treat them
more harshly whereas at one point we had
school equipping people by dealing with
them more harshly so that they went into
a world more equipped and I say this
because listen I know a lot of folks out
there sometimes you're trying to fix
this problem there where you feel
anxious where you feel like oh you're on
edge and and you don't know what to do
and I see a lot of times people go like
oh yeah you know I'm just I'm just so
tense
I'm just so edgy but I don't want to put
any more on my plate because I don't
think I could
no no you're edgy and anxious precisely
because you've got an empty plate son so
what I want you to do here I want you to
consider first everyone else out there
who's saying Millennials they have no
reason to be anxious actually they have
a lot of reasons to be anxious
unfortunately and that's because a lot
of us have failed them now if you're one
of those people who find yourself
anxious and you're not in the greatest
war ever well that would be the first
world war so I know some was gonna call
me on that but one of the most violent
certainly intimidating wars of all time
but you find yourself anxious I want you
to ask yourself what do you have on your
plate why is it ask yourself why is it
that your great-grandfather who killed
fitty man wasn't as anxious as you are
and he was in a pressure cooker what is
it that's missing there that's making
you anxious where you don't know what's
coming around the corner
what fight have you not picked I don't
mean this in a violent way let's start
with this if you feel anxious and it's
not because you're overworked it's not
because you're overburdened and a lot of
people feel that way right now with
coronavirus York Ovid 19 in their home
right they're home and they don't have
anything that they can do fill up your
plate pick a fight
pick something pick any fight find
something that is worthwhile for you to
get in the trenches over and go do it
and you know what sometimes if you're in
the trenches if you're in the heat of it
you don't have time to think about how
anxious you are because you're making
sure that you're not making the next
mistake that you're taking the right
steps so again if you find yourself
going I just I just feel so anxious I
feel empty maybe it's cuz you're
overworking you need some rest there are
some people but for a lot of you it's
because you are looking at a completely
empty plate and you're wondering what's
gonna be put on there no one's gonna put
anything on your plate you have to start
yourself find something that is worth
your time worth putting your energy into
worse more being your outlet for your
anxiety to accomplish something that
will help others and serve others in the
world this is a good time to figure it
out because you've got a lot of alone
time I don't want to see a plane Great
Escape Steve McQueen throwing that ball
against the wall in solitary I want you
to take this time rather than look back
upon it as a waste of time and go oh
that's why I replaced anxiety with
purposefulness and the results may
surprise you all right I will see you
next week good morning my Club Monday
live at 10 a.m. Eastern then the state
capital right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
Oh